it's pretty sad when CEOs in our country
business leaders job creators in our
country are afraid of what they might
say and have a government come come down
on them hi I'm Ted baliker with Reason
TV and today I'll be sitting down with
Brian Calle Calle is a columnist and
editorial writer for the Orange County
Register and producer of the CEO
solutions series
all right Brian wants you to tell me
about your CEO series the biggest issue
on everyone's mind today is job creation
President Obama is trying to create jobs
from the government level and all of his
jobs are essentially government jobs or
temporary jobs subsidized by the
government and so I said well who are
the real job creators let's go meet with
the CEO is the small business people who
are making the jobs work for we're
actually creating jobs in our country
and and so we decided that we were going
to create the CEO solution series we
started it with the CEO of Broadcom
we've done the CEO of Allergan the CEO
of Edwards Lifesciences people who are
who are in sectors that are growing now
technology and biotech sectors which are
growing now who are creating jobs and so
hey I said let's talk them see what they
have to say and and some of the stuff
that they said was was pretty startling
what did they say what were they what
was startling but the startling part was
that they have the opportunity to expand
and they could expand but they're
questioning whether or not they would
expand here here meaning in California
here meaning in the United States I
think historically if things weren't
good in California you'd move to
somewhere was more favorable like Nevada
but now they're saying you know this is
a global marketplace we're a global
company we don't have to be in the US we
could go to India we can go to Thailand
we can go anywhere else where conditions
market conditions are more favorable and
so these companies are companies I think
Broadcom hire 400 new people last year
in California these are companies like
Allergan who who hired I think a few
hundred people in California as well and
now given market conditions and
regulatory conditions specifically the
the Allergan in particular for Obamacare
the the passage is thinking to
themselves well this is going to impact
my industry you know the US isn't
necessarily the best place to be anymore
can you get into that a little bit more
how specifically would it affect them
they were saying that you know I think
it's billions and billions of dollars in
taxes for them to innovate in the United
States is this the the medical device
kind of medical device
tax and that would affect both Allergan
and Edwards Lifesciences obviously both
CEOs were very clear they'd like to
expand their companies and they would
like to grow their companies in the
United States but in the situation where
the government or government policies in
particular are hindering that growth the
choice is pretty clear they don't just
make these decisions lightly I mean
there are all sorts of reasons to stay
put from family ties to customer base
and so on so this is a big deal if they
up and leave
oh it's mean it would be a huge deal
both for I mean workers in our country
and for our economy it would be a huge
deal and they're not taking these
decisions lightly and every CEO I've
talked to is very very careful on what
they say obviously they have to be there
careful in terms of saying that they
love this country they love being in
this country they love what they've been
able to create in this country but but
they're also there their responses are
very nuanced because they're the public
face of their company but the underlying
story is kind of what they're what
they're not saying and what they don't
say or what they infer from from our
conversations is that you know let's
clean it up or or we're clearing out I
come across this a lot too when we talk
to business owners for pieces that we do
they'll say one thing to me on the phone
then I say can we get that on camera and
they clam up
you've in talking with you previously I
know you've come across quite a lot of
this what is sort of the unsaid that we
won't see I hear CEOs the common the
common thread is they're afraid to say
certain things on camera that they think
would put them in a position to be
targeted by bureaucrats targeted by you
the state you know the state government
or the federal administration things
like speaking to unkindly about specific
provisions in Obamacare speaking to
unkindly about specific regulations in
the state of California I've had a few
CEOs say that they didn't want to do the
series because they thought that it made
them too vulnerable it's pretty sad when
CEOs in our country business leaders job
creators in our country are afraid of
what they might say and have a
government come come down on them are
there things that specific things that
they're really worried about yeah you
the most interesting interview and it
was kind of the inspiration for for the
series and and and and continuing on in
the series was the interview with Scott
McGregor who's the CEO of Broadcom and
he actually outlined three areas where
he thought that government could do
things a little bit differently that
would help his his business obviously
which is something that a lot of
California CEOs talk about which is the
tax code in California the tax code in
California is egregious compared to many
other states and he said that reforming
the corporate tax code or at least
bringing it in line with other states
would be very helpful in terms of them
being able to hire more and to use more
of their capital towards investment and
innovation which would be critical for
for for a technology company the second
thing which I think is the most
interesting thing that's come out of the
CEO solution series so far was when he
told me that one simple switch in
California labor law would make them
more competitive globally which is that
you probably already know this but
California labor law is a little bit
more intense than the federal standards
and all he wants is for California to
regulate itself to the federal standard
right now in California they have the
provision that the that you can't work
more than an eight-hour work day without
paying being paid overtime whereas the
federal standards view this on a weekly
basis so it's a 40-hour workweek so all
he's saying is he wants to be able to go
to the federal standards because in
their industry they need to have someone
maybe working four days a week 10 hours
a day and the interesting thing about
that is it ends up hurting a lot of
workers who want the four-day workweek
but you know they're their bosses might
leave to places like Oregon where they
don't have this particular provision
because as you mentioned after the eight
hours boom you're on overtime now
exactly and I mean I was I was telling
this sounds like I worked more than ten
hours every day I thought that was just
kind of commonplace but now I mean
they're being exploited right yeah
exploited don't tell my boss well yeah
so so I think that the the that was the
biggest thing that came out of it which
is just a tiny little tweak like that
something that workers want in that
field something that would help us be
more globally competitive and something
that the the leadership of this company
is saying would be workable and they
still can't get that type of a change
so Broadcom CEO mentioned three things
the the labor law the
corporate income tax did we mention
before no the third was that was
education and so he and I might might
differ a little bit on this one but he
thought that we need to see public
education a little bit more invested in
in terms of science technology
engineering and mathematics education or
proficiency and I'd agree I think one of
the biggest areas where we need to grow
as a country is in our STEM education
science technology engineering and
mathematics you know the current way in
which our public education system works
and where the money comes from and the
federal involvement isn't something that
I'm very excited about per se but from
his perspective it's something that
needs to be invested about and there's
this widespread myth that corporate CEOs
are these cheerleaders for lazy fare
policies of course they're they're
willing to rigged the game in their
favor just like anyone else so there is
I think that's another interesting
aspect of your series the areas in which
these big businesses are actually
benefiting from the kind of collusion
with big government absolutely yeah
that's become part of the some some part
of the frustrating part of it because
you go into these meetings kind of a
wide-eyed and bushy tail you're like
yeah these guys are their free market
they want to they want to you know
change the playing field they want to
change this regulatory framework whereas
and in many cases to their credit they
do and in other cases they're there
regulations that are benefitting them
well they're self-interested so when it
helps them they want for your markets
when it hurts them they want regulations
exactly it's like Morton blackwell would
say the the status consensus in our
country and I think the status consensus
in Washington DC but there's also a
status consensus among among CEOs in our
country that if it if it benefits them
or if they can get a regulation passed
or a law passed it will hurt their
competition the more the better there
are all sorts of regulations that CEOs
know that they have to deal with but
then there's the unknown what's going to
come down the pipeline out of Sacramento
or DC in the future how how much does
this issue of uncertainty weigh on them
I think uncertainty is huge for for the
CEOs especially in California
because they're there it's kind of a
it's it's a two-prong death so to speak
whereas they're waiting for Sacramento
to kind of try to close a budget deficit
which will likely be on the backs of
business in California which are already
over
accent over-regulated and they also have
to worry about what's going to happen
with the Obama and registration and the
federal level so you see a lot of CEO
saying we hired X number of people last
year
now I'm sure how many we're gonna hire
this year we're gonna kind of wait
things out and see what's going to
happen a lot of CEOs are saying and this
is one of those off-camera things that
you mentioned they frankly want to wait
until after the election and see what
happens in November to see whether or
not they expand in California whether or
not they expand outside of California
whether or not they expand outside of
the United States so the uncertainty in
the marketplace is definitely impacting
job creation and unemployment numbers
and and definitely I think our broader
economic recovery and that's that's
lockstep every single CEO has mentioned
in in one way or another the uncertainty
in the marketplace be it the health care
bill be it financial regulations be it
what's going on in Sacramento and and
it's scary when those people who are the
ones who are really going to drive the
economic recovery of our country and get
people back to work are saying we're
going to hold off a bit because we don't
know what our government is going to do